[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 7 janvier
la priorité numéro un le vaccin a
martelé ce soir jean castex lors d'une
conférence de presse attendue principale
source d'espoir pour sortir de cette
épidémie de covile et le rythme qui va
s'accélérer 600 centres de vaccination
devraient être ouverts à la fin du mois
sur le front des restrictions lieu de
culturelles ou sportives bars et
restaurants devront rester fermé pour
l'instant
dès demain 10 départements
supplémentaires pourraient voir leur
couvre feu avancé à 18 heures joe biden
dénonce à l'instant l'un des jours les
plus sombres de notre histoire il
s'exprime en ce moment les états unis
sous le choc au lendemain de l'intrusion
des pros trump au capitole que
condamnent massivement la communauté
internationale quatre personnes y ont
perdu la vie
le congrès a certifié la victoire de joe
biden il y aura une transition ordonnée
le 20 janvier a promis de son côté le
président américain trump qui se trouve
de plus en plus isolé politiquement
isolé également sur les réseaux sociaux
donald trump banni de facebook pour une
durée indéterminée annonce de mark
zuckerberg tout à l'heure il aime pour
instagram quant au canal de
communication préférés du président
américain twitter c'est un blocage du
compte qui a été décrété hier pour 12
euros - laissant sur le carreau pas
moins de 88 millions d'abonnés en france
marine le pen évoque une censure nous
serons en direct de washington dans les
studios d'ayrté america notamment
[Musique]
le premier ministre a donc donné une
conférence de presse tout à l'heure pour
faire un point sur la situation
sanitaire et la campagne de vaccination
alors quelles sont les dernières
annonces sur le front du coc vide on
fait le point devant matignon avec katia
pique nique
bonsoir à katia que doit-on retenir de
cette prise de parole du premier
ministre et de ses ministres et bien
stéphanie beaucoup d'annoncés sur les
vaccins comme on s'y attendait mais tout
d'abord un point sur la situation
épidémique la circulation du virus reste
préoccupante on est bien loin des 5000
contamination par jour qui correspondent
à une épidémie maîtriser la pression sur
les hôpitaux restent fortes
et puis cette inquiétude l'apparition de
deux variant du virus un sud africain et
un britannique ce dernier de 40 à 70%
plus contagieux il existe deux clusters
de ce variant en bretagne en ile de
france il faut absolument éviter sa
diffusion
vous parliez tout à l'heure des lieux
qui resteront fermés les cinémas salles
de spectacles les remontées mécaniques
tous ces lieux dont vont le rester il y
aura un point d'étape le 20 janvier pour
étudier une réouverture potentiel le
début février donc toujours pas de
certitude mais le secteur sera soutenue
avec diverses z
et puis également le fameux couvre-feu
de 18h qui concerne 15 départements se
poursuivra il sera peut être étendu à 10
supplémentaires et puis ce qu'on
attendait évidemment la clarification du
plan vaccinal par jean castex on les
écoute
la campagne vaccinale contre la corrida
commencé le 27 décembre dernier et va se
poursuivre dans les mois à venir
elle suscite des attentes qui sont
légitimes mais aussi des interrogations
qui le sont tout autant
en revanche elle a donné lieu ces
derniers jours de la part de certains à
des propos et des critiques parfois
outrancier oui c'est vrai notre prof de
vaccination a démarré plus lentement que
dans d'autres pays ce décalage
s'explique par notre choix de respecter
les principes et nos priorités qui nous
ont été fixées par la haute autorité de
santé
alors il y a le problème de
l'autorisation des vaccins donc on sait
bien que la france a commandé 200
millions de vaccins mais ils ne seront
livrées que tout au long de 2021 il ya
des problèmes de production bien
évidemment mais il ya aussi donc la
question de l'autorisation seul trailer
était jusqu'au ce jusqu ici autorisée en
france le modern à l'est depuis hier
alors il y aura cinquante mille doses de
ce vaccin livrés dès lundi et puis des
millions dans les mois à venir ce qui
permettra on l'espère à la france de
rattraper son retard de vaccination en
retard par rapport à d'autres pays
d'europe
il ya six ans entre qui seront bientôt
ouverts 1 d'ici à deux semaines 600
centres de vaccination en france dans
les départements et puis il y a
également cette question des du passage
aux autres étapes de vaccination qui va
s'accélérer on écoute jean castex les
personnes de plus de 75 ans pourront se
faire vacciner à partir de lundi 18
janvier
ces vaccinations se dérouleront dans des
centres de vaccination un centre par
département a déjà été ouverts donc sans
sur le territoire à partir de lundi
prochain
il y en aura trois cents puis six ans
progressivement jusqu'à la fin du mois
de janvier alors un point positif tout
de même le système de dépistage
fonctionne très bien après mme un
cafouillage et pénurie ainsi il est
totalement gratuit contre 100 euros en
allemagne pour un dépistage et jusqu'à
350 euros en grande bretagne pour un pcr
est ainsi 3 5 millions de personnes ont
pu se faire vacciner la semaine avant
noël
merci katia technique en direct
depuis matignon et pour revenir sur ses
dernières annonces du gouvernement sur
la crise sanitaire place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités et pour en
parler nous sommes avec marc de lattes
député l'arrêt mme delenne médecins
généralistes bonsoir marc delattre merci
d'être avec nous à vos côtés louis
foucher médecin anesthésiste réanimateur
à l'hôpital de la conception membres du
groupe réinfectés ovide pardon s'il est
mal prononcé jean philippe dugoin
clément maire udi de mennecy
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france en charge également de
l'environnement bonsoir à tous les trois
merci d'être avec nous vous avez donc
évidemment suivi à cette allocution de
jean castex qui s'est achevée il ya
quelques minutes seulement marque de
l'art' je m'adresse aux députés de la
majorité que vous êtes mais aussi aux
médecins ce que vous avez été plutôt
satisfait des annonces de votre ministre
ce soir écoutez moi moi j'étais
pleinement satisfait de ce que le
premier ministre montre toute sa
responsabilité et toute sa pertinence
son discernement et qu'il en appelle à
la responsabilité collective
il est vrai que la situation reste
préoccupante quand un patient sur deux
en réanimation est un patient infecté
par l'aco vide
et effectivement le vaccin c'est une
plus qu'une lueur d'espoir mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'il ne faille pas
relâcher nos nos efforts et puis notre
vigilance sur les gestes barrières
voilà donc évidemment la situation est
maîtrisée il ya un pilote dans l'avion
comme on dit et il ne suffit pas de
s'agiter et comme un peu dans un bocal
comme j'entends beaucoup de mes
collègues politiques de l'opposition
pour justement décliner un plan qui est
tout à fait stratégique et efficient on
va prendre évidemment dans l'ordre ces
annonces en commençant par parler des
mesures de restriction parlera de la
vaccination dans un second temps il ya
bel et bien un pilote dans l'avion jean
philippe
du moins clément vous êtes d'accord avec
marc de l'acte il ya un gouvernement qui
est en place qui fait son travail avec
une certaine forme d'autosatisfaction
ben moi je note qu' on ne peut que
regretter collectivement que l'épidémie
ne soit pas maîtrisé que les chiffres
qui était envisagé pour début décembre
on en soit très loin ça tout ça ça
implique un ensemble de conséquences
graves pour l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes c'est tout le secteur de la
culture c'est tout le secteur du sport
c'est tout le secteur des loisirs qui va
continuer à être mis sous cloche avec
des gens qui tout simplement ne vivent
plus c'est toute la question des
universités qui n'a pas été évoquée ce
soir mais qui pose je crois un véritable
souci où on a une jeunesse aujourd'hui
qui est en situation de rupture d'un
point de vue éducatif mais également
d'un point de vue psychologique pour
beaucoup d'entre eux et c'est quelque
chose aujourd'hui je crois qu'il est
assez minimiser et on a été sur un
exercice qui est un exercice de points
d'information plus que deux
grand de deux grands exercices on va
mettre la table par terre très
clairement il n'y a pas eu ce soir
d'éléments qui n'étaient pas déjà connu
depuis 24 ou 48 heures qui a été
apportée en dehors de quelques éléments
extrêmement technique comme notamment
l'écart entre la première et la deuxième
dose de vaccin ce qui peut d'ailleurs
permettre peut-être d'avoir un petit peu
mais là je me retourne vers mais les
interlocuteurs médecin d'avoir un petit
peu plus de 2 me par rapport à la
gestion des arrivées des stocks
on va effectivement en parler jean
philippe dugoin clément parce que
c'était une annonce qui a peut avoir son
importance
effectivement je vous propose en tout
cas sur ces mesures de restriction
d'écouter jean castex qui effectivement
n'a pas fait de grande annonce mais en
tout cas annoncé plus tôt des mauvaises
nouvelles
qu'attendez de toute manière le monde de
la culture et le monde de la
restauration écoutez nous sommes loin de
l'objectif des 5000 cas par jour qui
correspond au seuil de maîtrise de
l'épidémie
la pression sur notre système de santé
restent élevés et nous ne sommes
toujours pas sorti d'affaires
nous devons retrouver une dynamique de
baisse
c'est la condition pour reprendre le
contrôle de l'épidémie
pour y parvenir cela me conduit à
arrêter les dispositions suivantes
premièrement toutes les activités tous
les établissements tous les équipements
qui sont aujourd'hui fermées et le
resteront encore jusqu'à la fin de ce
mois les musées les cinémas les théâtres
les salles de spectacle les équipements
sportifs ou de loisirs ne connaîtront
dans les semaines qui viennent
aucun assouplissement et louis foucher
rond on le sait un l'objectif est
évidemment de maîtriser les admissions à
l'hôpital vous êtes médecin anesthésiste
réanimateur s'avoue satisfait ces
mesures on imagine la déception mais
enfin il s'en douter malheureusement
pour eux les restaurateurs les bars les
restaurants qui sont pas prêtes de
rouvrir c'était un mal nécessaire ce
soit je vais d'abord me présenter en
fait je suis j'ai pas de conflit
d'intérêts tous les médecins qui doivent
parler sur les plateaux de télévision
doivent le dire c'est une obligation
légale
en fait à laquelle personne ne devrait
déroger 450 euros sur transparence santé
et j'ai eu aucun conflit d'intérêts et
je parle en mon nom et en tant que papa
parle du collectif raie infos que vous
devez sûrement pas pour mon institution
chien rester en bons termes avec mon
employeur je crois qu'il faut absolument
sortir du narratif que vous êtes en
train de tisser
j'ai absolument délirant et incohérent
jean castex en fait nous emmène dans un
chemin labyrinthique qui est absolument
fou il sort de son chapeau cette idée de
5000 cas par jour déjà il s'agit pas de
cas il s'agit de tests à sare skov deux
positifs avec des pcr donc savez pas
quels sont les seuils quels sont les
écueils très chaude qui sont utilisés
quels sont les kids qui sont utilisés
dans ces cas comme il les appelle mais
qui sont des tests positifs il ya 86 %
qui sont asymptomatiques et 93 à 97 %
qui sont asymptomatiques ou bénin de
condé dans un proprement un délire
d'avoir autant d'effets secondaires et
collatéraux sur notre société par toutes
les mesures qui sont réalisés par le
gouvernement
donc les gens sont pas malades du co
lead les gens sont malades des mesures
gouvernementales et sanitaires qui sont
entreprises ces mesures sont on pouvait
penser peut-être légitime au départ mais
l'expérience c'est pas la réitération à
l'infini de la même erreur et donc il
faut pas faire deux fois trois fois
quatre fois la même erreur
c'est le principe même du système
qualité qu'on nous serine à l'hôpital
depuis des années et dans tout les
secteurs de l'administration et de
l'entreprise c'est d'évaluer ce qu'on a
fait l'évaluation ce qu'on a fait c'est
qui a deux effets collatéraux explique
absolument phénoménaux sur l'université
comme l'a dit mon prédécesseur sur les
petits commerces sur des artisans sur le
niveau de détresse psychologique
affective social relationnel collectifs
et individuels et il faut absolument
arrêter ça donc toutes ces mesures
consistant à confiner à faire des
couvre-feux à empêcher les gens de
travailler sont en fait simplement pas
évalués à leur juste mesure il faut
évaluer le bénéfice et le risque le
risque est bien plus majeur que le
bénéfice d'ailleurs jamais évalué le
bénéfice réel sur la mortalité sur le
passage en réanimation sur les formes
graves sur les formes symptomatiques
lors de des vagues précédentes
donc s'il doit y avoir une troisième
paquet c'est fort possible
dans les eaux des égouts de marseille
par exemple on voit réapparaître le
virus et on voit apparaître la grippe
donc attention méfie la grippe va
arriver peut-être en même temps on
devrait on devrait évaluer parce qu'en
fait actuellement
toutes ces mesures là sont en train de
tuer notre économie de tuer notre
culture de tuer notre vie relationnelle
et notre société et nous emmène tout
doucement doucement doucement en fait
vers un déferlement totalitaire de que
mr blanc technos anita rist qui cherche
en fait à nous mettre en coupe réglée
sur des motifs sanitaires
ça n'a aucun rapport avec la santé ça
n'a aucun rapport avec ce qui se passe
en réanimation
actuellement le seul patients en
réanimation dans la réanimation où je
travaille il est là depuis un mois et
demi et hélas il a été très grave mais
on n'a pas de pression qui augmente pour
le moment mais je vous ai dit elle
risque d'augmenter effectivement dans
les eaux usées ça augmente
et puis il ya des cas le nombre de tests
positifs est en train d'augmenter
est ce que pour autant ça va être
quelque chose de très grave mais on n'en
sait rien pour le moment en fait et la
vaccination est un des outils
thérapeutiques et préventif mais c'est
un dé et finalement quand on vous parle
de la fourniture de vaccins quand est-ce
qu'ils vont arriver quand est ce qu'on
va me mettre en oeuvre dans quel barnum
où on vous empêche de réfléchir à quelle
est la stratégie nous en tant que
soignant on doit à fléchir la stratégie
il ya des stratégies alternatives
thérapeutiques qui fonctionne en fait et
donc vous devez comparer la stratégie
vaccinale à une stratégie intelligente
bien mené avec des traitements
antiviraux et c'est tout est basé dans
l'est même conditionnelle qui a cours
actuellement et qui a permis d'exister
au niveau enfin on va prendre chaque
problème dans l'ordre en tout cas c'est
intéressant ce que vous nous dites lui
foucher parce qu'on a l'impression que
cette petite voix finalement le sauté de
plus en plus est la population devient
résignés face à l'ampleur en tout cas
des chiffres globaux sur la planète et
parce qu'aussi peut-être nos voisins eux
ont des mesures encore plus sévères
marque de lattes c'est intéressant parce
que c'est vrai que voilà l'économie
est en train d'être tués ça personne ne
le conteste même s'il y a des aides un
jean castex l'a rappelé les restaurants
mais aussi les stations de ski qui
seront toujours pas fixé les stations de
ski c'est pas que pour les gens qui vont
faire du ski mais c'est aussi beaucoup
pour les saisonniers pour cette
industrie qui est énorme qui ne sont pas
fixés ce soir est ce que ça justifie
est-ce que la gravité de ce virus
justifie comme le maire en cause ce soir
8 foucher selon vous vous êtes également
médecin je le rappelle déjà pour pour
les mesures dans l'économie on n'est pas
là pour tuer l'industrie mais au
contraire la soutenir puisque les
mesures de chômage partiel permettent
justement les fonds de solidarité qui
vont être pérennisée et permettent aussi
à nos tpe pme comme je le vois chez moi
de pouvoir surmonter cette crise donc
premièrement je m'inscris absolument
faux dans la mesure où nous avons jamais
déployé autant de moyens regardé par
rapport aux états unis par rapport à
d'autres pays
tout ce que fait la france pour soutenir
l'entreprise donc on on ne tue pas
l'entreprise
au contraire on veut absolument la
sauver premièrement deuxièmement je ne
je ne comparerai pas les centres de
vaccination à un barnum j'ai trop de
respect pour mes collègues soignants et
dès demain d'ailleurs je les
rencontrerai l'hôpital pour dire que
justement il y aura des centres de
vaccination je vois dans ma
circonscription au centre hospitalier de
chénier et de soi sans il ya des centres
de vaccination et je compte bien dès la
semaine prochaine
m'employer pour l'assurer aussi une
vacation à l'hôpital de 60 c c'est a
priori prévu et en accord avec la grèce
et le directeur de l'établissement
ensuite pour vous dire que les français
en plus en plus confiance en notre
politique c'est de vaccinale c'est que
d'autant plus que la communication est
claire nette et précise et 51% de la
dépasser la barre des 2 plus de 51% de
50% des français qui veulent se faire
vacciner
donc je pense que arrêtons d'être
cassandre et mais justement faisant
confiance
la stratégie vaccinale qui je répète la
vie
que du comité scientifique présidé par
le président delfraissy
et quand même souverain assez haut
niveau quand à conseiller et à orienter
les choix politiques qui sont moi je
pense que vraiment on a et moi qui suis
membre du conseil consultatif national
d'éthique dieu connaît personnellement
c'est juste des gens de très grande
qualité et qui ont tous les discernement
et des capacités de par leur leur cursus
pour nous aider et nous donner leur avis
pour guider justement notre stratégie
des vaccins marc delattre on va écouter
justement jean castex qui nous annonce
45000 personnes vaccinées hier et
l'objectif d'un million à la fin j'en
viens écouter le premier ministre à très
court terme d'ici fin janvier
les quantités reçues et qui arrive au
cours du mois nous permettant d'être en
capacité de vacciner au moins un million
de personnes soit le même nombre que nos
voisins européens au prorata de notre
population
ce rythme est celui des capacités
industrielles qui sont aujourd'hui en
forte tension
nous veillerons à acheminer des doses de
vaccin sur l'ensemble du territoire
national y compris dans les départements
d'outre-mer et jean philippe dugoin
clément on sent que le premier ministre
n'a pas envie d'être le mauvais élève
européen après avoir essuyé une salve de
critiques il vous a convaincu vous
pensez qu'il ya une amélioration sur
cette stratégie de vaccination en france
on prend un bon chemin où c'est plutôt
mal parti ni selon vous le gouvernement
essaye de rattraper une situation où il
a pris beaucoup de retard même si on est
drôle d'un phénomène d'auto satisfaction
ou le premier ministre comme la ministre
de la santé ne le diront pas mais on a
pris énormément de retard par rapport à
nos voisins par rapport à d'autres pays
on pourrait parler d'israël on pourrait
parler de la grande-bretagne orser
faivre bretagne depuis le 31 décembre
n'est plus dans l'union européenne mais
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya une volonté
d'essayer de redresser la barre là
dessus bon moi je suis quand même assez
aujourd'hui inquiet sur lequel est le
pilote enfin il ya eu toutes ces
questions par rapport à des cabinets
prix
v mené ayant été chargée d'établir une
stratégie qu'ils sont qui sont-ils
pourquoi faire payer par qui quel coup a
priori gand nord nous a parlé d'un
cabinet initialement on en est à 4
aujourd'hui donc le pilote de l'avion
c'est qui et je trouve qu'on a depuis
une quinzaine de jours une sorte de
flottement extrêmement fort entre le
président de la république d'un côté le
comité scientifique d'un autre le
conseil de défense
un comité citoyen convient de mettre en
place il a ses cabinets d'études qui
viennent d'être découverts je pense
qu'on a effectivement besoin d'avoir un
cap aujourd'hui les gens font
relativement sceptique faut dire les
choses telles qu ils sont par rapport à
la puissance publique
les gens ont besoin d'avoir des
résultats d'avoir des perspectives et
aujourd'hui on manque de résultats et de
perspectives
c'est ce qui importe c'est de pouvoir
juger sur pièce de voir vers quoi on va
moi j'aurais aimé ce soir que le premier
ministre prenne la main qui lui a été
tendu par les présidents de région les
présidents de région ont fait 9
propositions pour travailler avec l'état
sur la situation sanitaire c'est quelque
chose qui a été gentiment botté en
touche avec de sourires et de rod et de
rodomontades
mais où concrètement il n'y a pas eu de
souhait de travailler avec les
collectivités locales je le regrette
c'est vrai qu' il n'y a pas eu de mots 1
vous avez raison
pour répondre à ces présidents de région
qui ont tendu la main au gouvernement
louis foucher on a entendu premier
ministre se justifier de cette lenteur
au démarrage par le fait qu'on a choisi
de vacciner dans les ehpad c'est audible
pour vous parce que c'est vrai qu'on
entende et jean castex qu'on avait
l'impression tout avait été très bien
fait en terme de campagne de vaccination
pour le moment en tout cas on se
contrefout des modalités pratiques de la
campagne de vaccination en fait c'est
une narration dans laquelle on vous
emmène vous empêcher de réfléchir
réellement au fond au fond c est ce que
ce vaccin est utile est ce qu'il est
risqué ce qu'il est prudent de le faire
est-ce que la balance bénéfice risque a
été bien pesé on cherche à vous emmener
toujours dans une narration disruptive a
essayé de vous couper l'herbe sous le
pied on pourra toujours aller plus vite
on est toujours en retard on serait du
droit
il faudrait se mettre en conformité
c'est du délire est-ce que vous avez
déjà pris une décision de votre vie dans
la précipitation et dans la peur qu'ils
se soient révélés une bonne décision
ah non donc en fait vous devez prendre
le temps de regarder les seules données
que vous avez sur ce vaccin freezer
biotech pour le moment sont celles
fournies par le laboratoire sur un essai
de phase iii même laboratoire qui a été
condamné sur ces dix dernières années à
plus de 800 millions heureux de dollars
deux condamnations pour données
frauduleuses pour falsification de
données et publicité mensongère
donc vous devez à tout le moins être
prudents que vous dit aristote il vous
dit soyez dans la frénésie ce
l'intelligence du courage la prudence en
fait la sagesse contextuel la salle
juste contextuel c'est de regarder c'est
sûrement un très bon outil que les
vaccins dans cette histoire mais ce
vaccin là vous n'avez aucun recul dessus
donc en fait vous devez regarder
l'efficacité chez les plus de 75 ans par
exemple dans l'essai de phase iii
l'intervalle de conscient de confiance
va de -12 à 100 donc en fait vous ne pas
conclure c'est absolument pas
significatif savais même pas si ça
protège ou si c'est toxique donc vous en
savez rien de même sur les effets
secondaires dans les cinq premiers jours
le cdc a fait un rapport d'étape qui a
montré qu'il y avait plus de 2,8 pour
cent des faits secondaires qui induisait
des arrêts de travail prolongé à une
cessation de l'activité quotidienne
normale pendant plus de 48 heures donc
là on est attendu restons calmes toi
regardons soyons prudents en fait et
donc moi je suis très content que ça
patine au démarrage
parce que ça permet de protéger mes
concitoyens et dans la laisser aller
regarder en face quels sont les vrais
data dont on dispose pour savoir si ce
vaccin est sûre s'il est efficace et si
on devrait pas prendre son temps et puis
les laisser regarder autre chose c'est
toutes les thérapeutiques alternatives
qui sont en train de se faire jour au
cours des études que ce soit le cuivre
la vitamine d la vitamine c hydroxy
chloroquine le zinc le site rom axe et
l'ivermectine toutes ces stratégies là
n'ont même pas été regardé en face alors
qu'elles sont hyper intéressante de
létalité à 10h et marseille pour ceux
qui sont traités ne serait ce qu'avec
une toute petite partie de ce que je
viens de dire succès en france rappelle
guy faucher
vous n'avez pas été entendu cette souris
n'est ce que disent les médias
mainstream aller regarder les travaux
qui sont faits ya plus de 200 études sur
le sujet que 170 études empiriques
review
il faut regarder en face je crois que
vos téléspectateurs doivent aller
regarder ses 19 7 à 10 le tweeter d'eric
chabrières la chaîne youtube de lier à
chu à la chaîne youtube de reinfo
qu'ovide et puis à un moment regarder en
face le fait que bfm leur racontent
n'importe quoi le point les échos etc
ça tombe bien on va donner la parole à
marc de latvala qui effectivement
réagissez à ce que vous dites mais voilà
c'est vrai que marc delattre ce que dit
votre confrère parce qu'il est aussi
médecin
eh bien il faut l'entendre parce que
c'est ce que pense aussi une partie peut
être des français qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez à on vous parlait d'ailleurs
des plus de 75 ans ils vont se faire
vacciner à partir du 18 janvier a dit
jean castex
j'ai lu ce que j'ai entendu c'est ici et
c'est confondant j'ai pas s'il faut en
rire ou en pleurer en tout cas vos
téléspectateurs
mon chien je pense que le cuivre ou le
zinc n'ont pas montré d'effets sur le
lac au vide et quoi qu'il en soit on a
on a commencé à vacciner skull 27
décembre et on est toujours allé voir
les études vous devez travailler mais je
vais commencer à travailler c'est là
quelque chose
nous avons des certitudes à bord c'est
sauver des vies et merci au ministère de
la santé merci à l'ensemble des
soignants et il faut bien savoir que
c'est le vaccin c'est une s'il n'ya pas
d'autre alternative et que ce médecin on
l'a bien il ya un postulat il faut
certes ce vaccin permet d'éviter des
complications potentiellement létale il
est normal éthiquement normal que nous
vaccinons en premier lieu dans les ehpad
dans les unités de soins de longues
dents de l'endurer pour sauver justement
ces personnes les plus fragilisées
et puis en face d'eux bien sûr les
personnes de plus de 75 ans dès le 18
juin
donc arrêtons ces ces inepties fois ci
c'est incroyable d'entendre ça encore
nous croyons au moyen-âge et donc le le
vaccin il est joint du jeu rappelle je
m'adresse vraiment côté des spectateurs
qui regardent votre chaîne s'est évité
c'est pour éviter les complications
potentiellement létale et ça permettra
aussi de désengorger nos services de
réanimation
sachant le après les incertitudes sur ce
vaccin
combien de temps il va il va faire en
sorte qu'une soyons immunisés
support on subodore en tout cas la
comité de scientifiques que ça sera
entre six et neuf mois un peu comme le
vaccin de la grippe que cette diminuera
la propagation du virus
on le subodore aussi mais l'essentiel
c'est que ça sauve des vies que ça
diminue les complications
potentiellement létale de ces essais
voilà à quoi mais quand j'entends le
cuivre le zinc mais dans quel monde vous
vivez monsieur jamais vraiment je ne
sais pas moi j'ai un petit peu honte
pour la profession médicale devient la
notice du village simplement aller lire
la notice du village vous en supplie
mais d'aller voir qu'en fait les sept
grandes up a été calibré pour regarder
s'il ya moins de moins de chance et qui
vous ferait animations avoir une et c
est moins de forme grave
donc en fait vous êtes en train de dire
n'importe quoi à l'envers ce de la
science avéré le conseil de l'ordre a
pourrait même vous poursuivre pour ça on
vous mettra pas d'accord ce soit en tout
cas les deux opinions a été clairement
dit
ce soir jean philippe dugoin clément
regarder sans fin oui ça vous inspire
quoi justement parce que se démarque
finalement c'est le 2 le reflet de la
société française aujourd'hui avec
beaucoup de scepticisme dans le pays et
puis la nécessité pour beaucoup d'autres
médecins et bien de vacciner qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire assez rapidement
s'il vous plaît parce qu'on arrive à la
fin de ce débat qu'on est dans une
société qui est fracturée aujourd'hui il
ya la moitié des gens qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner l'autre moitié qui sont
inquiètes ou qu'on des réticences par
rapport à ce sujet là et où je pense que
si on veut aller au delà des réticences
ou des peurs par rapport au vaccin et
bien déjà c'est d'arriver à décliner des
protocoles de vaccination qu'ils soient
efficaces qu'ils aillent vite qu'ils
puissent faire que de proche en proche
des gens décident de se faire vacciner
que un certain nombre d'élus nationaux
de
le hummer l'exemple d'assumer le fait
d'être prêts à se faire vacciner
en angleterre la reine d'angleterre
s'est fait vacciner pourquoi est ce que
le ministre de la santé le premier
ministre le président de la république
ne le font pas je pense que c'est aussi
un moyen de rassurer des craintes
et puis au delà de ça au delà de la
question du vaccin je crois qu'il ya un
vrai sujet il ya eu ainsi gurs de la
santé qui a été annoncé avant l'été
on sait qu'on est dans une situation
épidémique importante que dans les
années qui viennent on peut avoir
d'autres virus de ce type
qu'est ce qui a été fait pour essayer de
mettre un coup d'arrêt à la
paupérisation de l'hôpital français et
du système de santé français qu'on a
subi une quinzaine d'années ce qui est
pas du fait d'ailleurs de ce
gouvernement actuellement qu'est ce qui
a été fait pour essayer d'adapter nos
réponses en termes de soins à des
besoins qui vont aller je le crains dans
les années qui viennent en grandissant
parce qu'on est aussi confronté un
certain nombre d'évolutions de
l'environnement sont me dégoûtent de
deux confrontations à la pollution un
certain nombre d'accélérations des
mobilités qui font que ce type de
pandémie mondiale est susceptible de
beaucoup plus se développer rapidement
et beaucoup plus se renouveler qu'il y a
encore quelques années
merci à tous les trois en tout cas jean
philippe dugoin clément louis foucher et
marc de lattes d'avoir été avec nous
pour ce décryptage ce soir merci à vous
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
nous reviendrons sur les événements
survenus hier au capitole aux états unis
avec des images qui resteront gravés
dans les mémoires celle d'un coup de
force des programmes dans le temple de
la démocratie américaine et joe biden
qui s'est exprimé d'ailleurs ce soir il
demande la destitution de jo
donald trump et puis nous parlerons des
réseaux sociaux et qui dans la foulée
des violences ont suspendu les comptes
du président sortant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
20h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus si vous nous rejoignez en
direct sur rt france joe biden vient de
s'exprimer depuis le delaware le
président-élu dénonçant des jours les
plus sombres de l'histoire américaine et
accuse donald trump d'avoir déchaîné je
suis un assaut sans merci contre les
institutions démocratiques direction
tout de suite
washington au lendemain de ces
événements qui se sont donc produits au
capitole ont lieu de la démocratie
américaine
je vous rappelle que quatre personnes y
ont perdu la vie aujourd'hui le chef des
démocrates au sénat appel à des maîtres
donald trump de ses fonctions rejoint
par nancy pelosi ce soir d'aimer trump
est une urgence de la plus haute
importance nous dit-elle direction tout
de suite
washington avec ventura présentateur
d'ayrté america bonsoir dahirel venture
à merci d'être avec nous devons le
capitole 1 où se sont produits hier soir
ces événements qu'on a suivi un petit
peu éberlués un aussi en direct depuis
la france l'amérique
on imagine qui s'est réveillée groggy au
lendemain de ces événements inédits
oui en effet nous sommes tous que robbie
après ces événements c'est moi qui me
pris place dans notre capitale c'était
inattendu c'est très effrayant et c'est
une insulte pour ceux que notre pays
représente la transition politique
pacifique
cela nous rappelle presque les actions
que nous avons menées dans d'autres pays
dans le monde entier
lorsque nous avons poussé en avant des
transitions difficiles et voir cela sur
notre propre territoire c'était vraiment
un choc car cela aurait été très
facilement évitables se retrouve isolé
politiquement aujourd'hui on a vu que
ses alliés international même les plus
précieux le lâchaient un peu hein
avec cette nouvelle et dernière réaction
de ben jonson aussi une grande partie
peut-être des républicains sur place est
ce qu'on peut parler aujourd'hui d'un
président sortant isolé
[Musique]
complètement isolé il ya même des
rumeurs qu'on ferait jouer le 25e
amendement qui le rêve a créé pour une
incapacité à gouverner pour difficultés
mentales
à peine deux semaines de la transition
de pouvoir vers djerba et l onu 20
janvier je baille dunn est très isolé
même au sein de ce parti des membres de
son cabinet démissionne alors que le
navire coule et il sera très intéressant
de voir ce qui va arriver au cours des
jours à venir
le 25e amendement sera-t-il invoqué pour
révoquer de notre hôte et le pen sera
alors au pouvoir
nous ne savons pas ce qui va arriver
mais la rumeur court en tous cas dans le
voisinage et la situation très difficile
pour donald trump justement tard elle
cette petite voie qui consisterait à
démettre donald trump elle se fait de
plus en plus entendre notamment dans le
camp des démocrates
le chef vous l'avez dit des sénateurs
est aussi à l'instant nancy pelosi on la
connaît pour être une farouche opposante
à donald trump est elle dit que c'est
une urgence de la plus haute importance
de démettre le président sortant il ya
ce risque là qu'il ne termine pas ce
mandat donald trump
bhatti est peut-être un risque qu'ils
agissent très rapidement surtout après
ce qui est arrivé ce 6 janvier aux etats
unis ajoute une foule à envahir le
capitole est effectivement c'était
effrayant on pourrait avoir peur d'une
récurrence et donald trump qui possède
également les codes nucléaires de cos il
a complètement perdu pied avec la
réalité alors c'est dangereux mais nous
sommes sûrs de rien il ne s'agit que de
rumeurs et de spéculations ne sais pas
ce qui va arriver mais est ce une
possibilité certainement notamment après
ce qui est arrivé hier six en tout cas
il s'agissait assez rapidement alors on
parlait adventures à de donald trump est
isolé politiquement mais isolé également
et ça ça doit être douloureux pour le
président américain sur les réseaux
sociaux on a censuré ses comptes twitter
instagram et facebook
voies de communication directe qu'il a
utilisé plus que tout autre président
dans l'histoire des états unis
il s'en servait pour parler directement
à ses partisans ces gens qui ont voté
pour lui il s est tourné vers son
twitter et maintenant que cela est
bloqué alors le voilà obligé de
communiquer au travers de son équipe
tout ce système qui le déteste donc
c'est une posture tout à fait nouvelle
pour lyon la suspension de twitter n'est
pas sainte est fini mais en tout cas
effectivement cela change tout à fait la
situation pour donald parce que c'était
une petit de communication majeur toutes
ses partisans le suivre via son compte
twitter
rome a évoqué pour la première fois une
transition ordonnée joe biden quant à
lui a été officiellement certifié un
validé par le congrès sa victoire en
tout cas ça veut dire voilà que ça prend
forme
désormais de notre homme va passer la
main et laisser la place clairement à
joe biden
defraigne a aucun autre chemin pour lui
il n'y a aucune autre contestations
juridiques possibles comme vous le voyez
ils ont déjà mis en place une estrade
pour une opération de joe dalton qui
aura lieu le 20 janvier
donc les engrenages la transition avant
ce que donne à 39 toulon il s'est mis
lui même dans cette position au cours
des derniers mois la mis tous ses oeufs
dans le même panier en espérant qu'ils
pourraient renverser le résultat de
l'élection
mais il n'y avait aucune raison qu'il
réussisse à le faire va devenir le
prochain président des états unis le 20
janvier 21 et donald trump et ses
partisans vont devoir le regardais tout
simplement depuis les coulisses merci
beaucoup à l aventure à présentateur
berthet america en direct depuis
washington merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous et le congo on a dit a tout de
même pu valider la victoire de joe biden
à la présidentielle après le rejet des
objections émises par les républicains
le vice président mike pence a confirmé
la victoire du démocrate avec 306 grands
électeurs contre 232 pour donald trump
alors que s'est-il passé hier soir à
washington avançait certification retour
sur cette nuit qui a fait vaciller
l'amérique avec mathilde romagnan
[Applaudissements]
scènes de chaos à washington le congrès
temple de la démocratie américaine est
pris d'assaut par les partisans de
donald trump
[Applaudissements]
ils étaient des milliers hier dans la
capitale fédérale répondant à l'appel de
leurs candidats lors d'un discours
prononcé quelques heures avant les faits
le président sortant confirme qu'il
n'accepterait pas la défaite nous tous
ici présents ne voulons pas voir notre
victoire électorale volés par des
démocrates plein d'audace de la gauche
radicale car c'est ce qu'ils font est
volé par les pseudo médias car c'est ce
qu'ils ont fait et ce qu'ils sont en
train de faire
nous n'abandonnerons jamais nous ne
concédons jamais c'était hier que le
sénat devait valider la victoire de joe
biden envahi de manifestants pro tron
la séance a dû être interrompue les
militaires de la garde nationale ont été
envoyés pour rétablir le calme
la police a annoncé la mort d'une femme
décédée des suites de ses blessures
après avoir été blessé par balle à
l'intérieur du capitole
[Applaudissements]
trois autres personnes sont mortes dans
les environs du capitole dans la soirée
un couvre-feu a été instauré à
washington en fin d'après midi des
manifestants sont toujours à l'extérieur
du bâtiment
dans une vidéo enregistrée dans la
soirée à la maison blanche donald trump
s'adresse à ses partisans je connais
votre douleur je sais que vous êtes
blessé qui nous avons eu une élection
qui nous a été volé mais vous devez
rentrer chez vous maintenant il nous
faut de la paix after peace
les sénateurs ont pu regagner leur place
dans l'hémicycle sous escorte lourde
la séance a repris après un discours de
la présidente de la chambre des
représentants nancy pelosi
oui madame aubé nous devons montrer et
nous le ferons au pays et même au monde
entier que nous ne serons pas détourner
de notre devoir que nous respecterons
notre responsabilité envers la
constitution et le peuple américain à
ceux qui se sont efforcés de nous
arracher à nos responsabilités
vous avez échoué nous à faire swinguer à
ceux qui se sont livrés à la joyeuse
profanation de notre temple de la
démocratie la démocratie américaine
justice sera faite pias whedon des
américains qui envahissent le capitole
une première dans l'histoire des états
unis
et on continue à parler de ces
événements aux états unis on retour en à
washington pour notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur et nous sommes sur place
avec un tristan cabello maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine à
la johns hopkins et neva city bonsoir et
bonjour pour vous tristan cabello
comment nommer ce qui s'est passé on a
tout entendu en sédition c'est ce qu'a
dit joe biden insurrection baroud
d'honneur farce tentative de coup d'état
est ce qu'on y voit plus clair ce soir
alors on ne sait toujours pas vraiment
ce qui s'est passé hier après-midi ce
que je peux vous dire ici c'est que je
voyais votre bandeau tout à l'heure kids
l amérique sidéré et c'est exactement ce
qui se passe c'est être que les
américains ne sont pas un peuple de
manifestants revendicateurs ils n'ont
pas du tout la culture et d'amis de la
manifestation de rue et donc ce qui
s'est passé hier c'était quelque chose
de tout à fait nouveau un pur est pour
les américains de tout à fait
traumatisant un certain point c'est à
dire que ce matin on s'est réveillé avec
tous dans nos boîtes emails des emails
d'employeurs de collectivités locales
d'université qui nous vous inviter à
consulter les cellules de crise les
numéros verts pour parler de du stress
du traumatisme qu'on a vécu hier donc ce
qui s'est passé à dire c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très important c'est
absolument sidérant pour beaucoup pour
beaucoup d'américains alors est ce que
c'est un coup d'état et que simplement
un problème de sécurité qui n'a pas bien
marché je crois que les historiens ne
diront en temps voulu et je crois que
les enquêtes nous donnerons un peu plus
de réponses est ce qu'on peut dire ce
soir que la démocratie américaine a été
clairement mis en échec alors nous la
démocratie américaine n'a pas été mise
en échec
il faut quand même rappeler que durant
la pandémie
on a eu quelque chose comme 65 70 % de
de participation peut-être plus haut
taux depuis 30 ans ça ne s'était jamais
vu depuis vraiment très longtemps et
puis hier ce qui s'est passé c'est
vraiment je crois un défaut de sécurité
je crois que il faut quand même dire aux
téléspectateurs que tous les gens qui
vivent à washington qui ont eu accès au
capitole à la maison blanche savent très
bien qu'il est très difficile d'y avoir
accès et que quand on n'y a accès il
faut passer à travers des couches de
sécurité qui sont vraiment très longue
est vraiment lourde et d'ailleurs durant
la plupart des manifestations qu'il ya
eu cet été pour black ice matters
l'égard de la garde nationale protéger
ses bâtiments
donc là je crois qu'il va falloir
vraiment faire une enquête et sans
risque peut-être ce qui s'était passé
parce que dès que la question qui est
sur toutes les lèvres ici à washington
c'est comment ces manifestants ont pu
rentrer dans des buildings qui sont
aussi protégés
la police du capitole en tout cas s'est
déclaré bien seul s'est senti abandonné
at-elle dit et c'est vrai que la garde
nationale finalement n'a pas été envoyée
sous l'ordre de donald trump et que la
police fédérale un petit peu abandonné
la police du capitole sur place en tout
cas ce sont allés mohand cette police du
capitole tout à fait alors y avait
beaucoup de dysfonctionnements au niveau
de la police du capitole on ne sait pas
encore précisément ce qui s'est passé ce
que l'on voit c'est des tweets un peu et
bars de gens de personnes qui
travaillent pour le capitole et qui
disent que dès le début de la matinée
ils ont le temps en fait renvoyer chez
eux et on voit très bien qu'ils étaient
dans le voit se regroupent les images en
sous-effectif et que c'est tout à fait
c'est tout à fait inconscient c'est tout
à fait une anomalie puisque je rappelle
que quand même
la manifestation avait commencé très tôt
le matin et que en plus de cela il se
passait quand même
au capitole ce jour là un vote de la
plus haute importance
donc on se demande vraiment pourquoi ces
bâtiments n'ont pas été plus protégés
pourquoi il était aussi facile
finalement d'y rentrer faut quand même
se rappeler que pendant les
manifestations par exemple la classe
matters ou la women's match qui a eu
lieu juste après des élections de noël
train lagarde était déjà sur les marches
du capitole
on ne pouvait même pas aller sur les
marches du capitole comment ont-ils fait
pour pour parvenir à l'intérieur c'est
vraiment la grande question là alors joe
biden s'est exprimé il ya quelques
minutes
il a accusé donald trump de se livrer un
assaut sans merci contre toutes les
institutions la question évidemment
qu'on peut se poser aujourd'hui c'est
comment donald trump va sortir de cet
épisode
est-ce que même ses plus fervents
supporters vont continuer à le soutenir
aujourd'hui alors l'impression qu'il
donnait hier c'était vraiment que le
train n'est même plus à la hauteur du 36
mhz
j'ai envie de dire que c'était quelqu'un
qui donnait l'impression d'avoir été
dépassé par le propre parle enthousiasme
de ses propres soutiens et on l'a bien
fait je crois qu'il a lancé cette idée
du capitole le matin sans vraiment
savoir si ça allait vraiment se
matérialiser alors moi je crois qu'il
faut quand même s'en excuser la violence
et tout en rappelant que c'était une
minorité un d'américains qui se sont
emparés du du capital et c'est quand
même de comprendre ce qui se passe
puisque encore une fois mais rien ne
sont pas un peuple qui attendent
beaucoup de leur gouvernement
pourtant là il s'enquit une fraction 1
de l'amérique est quand même à beaucoup
plus grandes que ce qu'on a vu hier
puisque ce matin il y avait un sondage
qui rappelait que 45% des républicains
des gens qui ont voté pour trump en fait
soutenait un la prise du capitole donc
c'est quand même un certain nombre de
gens une frange quand même importante de
l'électorat républicain et donc le tran
piste va continuer le tremper exiter
existait sous d'autres formats 20 30
n'est ce qui est quand même assez
évident non là c'est que trump a été
complètement débordés et maintenant
lâché par sa
repro administration et par sa propre
son propre parti c'est quelqu'un qui est
quand même assez isolé maintenant à
tristan cas vidéo vous faites donc posé
la question parce que c'est important de
le faire de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé vous avez dit ce sondage qui est
assez édifiant on entend les
manifestants et les soupirs de trump
dire mais nous on a été méprisée on nous
a volé notre élection est ce qu'il faut
quand même entendre cette voix là aussi
absolument il faut absolument comprendre
ce qui s'est passé faut absolument alors
vous voulez d'élections ça je ne ne
crois pas c'est à dire que il ya eu
quand même des 60 à peu près 60 procès
je crois soixante huit requête de donald
trump pour pour essayer de d'invalider
des scrutins dont vous les élections
n'ont par contre je crois qu'il ne faut
pas mépriser ce mouvement je crois qu'il
faut absolument entendre ce qui se passe
là ce qui se passe là c'est très simple
c'est à dire s'il ya une grande 10
connexion déconnexion entre les élites
et le peuple et ce peuple qui étaient là
au capitole hier c'est finalement un
peuple qui ne sait plus où il va et qui
naquit n'a aussi financer les moyens de
ses rêves
donc ce sont des gens qui qui ont
beaucoup de peu de problèmes à boucler
les fins de mois
alors là la réponse que donne à 30 leur
donner c'était que bon voilà le
gouvernement ne fait pas assez pour vous
c'est une réponse assez typique de la
droite conservatrice
ils sont achetés ça je crois qu'il ya
d'autres moyens de parler à cette frange
de l'électorat va avec d'autres idées
peut-être que c'est pas by john
peut-être que ce sera quelqu'un d'autre
mais en tout cas ce qui s'est passé hier
je crois qu'il faut absolument pas
mépriser cette frange de l'amérique il
faut aussi tenter vraiment de comprendre
ce qui s'est passé des raisons pour
lesquelles ils se sont rebellés
d'une manière assez forte est ce que les
médias américains ont fait suffisamment
justement d'essayer de comprendre parce
qu'on entendait beaucoup de manifestants
d'hier aussi on se sent méprisée par les
médias américains ce que ces médias
n'ont pas
et un rôle finalement dans cette colère
je pense que cette frange de la
population et 2 passes ont méprisé par
toutes les élites puisqu'il n'arrive pas
à comprendre comment un grand une grande
déconnection à c'est à dire entre les
élites et le peuple je ne dis pas que
ces gens qui étaient hier au capitole
représente tout le peuple américain mais
je rappelle quand même pas aux
téléspectateurs que il y aura 15 % de
chômage ou à la fin du mois il ya à peu
près tous millions de gens aux états
unis qui ne peuvent pas payer leurs
employés et il y à peu près 60% de gens
aux états unis qui n'ont pas 400 dollars
sur leur compte épargne
donc il faut quand même rappeler qu' il
ya une grande partie des américains la
majorité des américains qui ont du mal à
boucler des fins de mois et je pense que
ces gens là disait hier à leur manière
c'était ça c'était c'est une expression
de cette peur cette peur du déclassement
de déclassement qui arrivent déjà de
toute façon est qui et qui est vraiment
bien là et qui ne trouve absolument
aucune réponse dans les politiques qui
leur sont proposés merci beaucoup
tristan cabello maître de conférences en
civilisation américaine à johnson city
et on l'a évoqué avec nos invités
twitter et facebook ont suspendu les
comptes du président américain une
décision inédite après une vidéo du
milliardaire qui appelait les
manifestants devant le capitole à
rentrer chez eux sont condamnés pour
autant leur intrusion
le président sortant pourrait même voir
son compte twitter suspendu
définitivement les détails avec solène
gaudin c'est le tweet de trop ce
mercredi le réseau social twitter à
retirer une vidéo postée par donald
trump dans cette publication
le président américain s'adressait aux
manifestants qui ont envahi le capitole
leur demandant de rentrer chez eux mais
déclarant sans preuve que l'élection
présidentielle du 3 novembre dernier lui
avait été volé
nous avons une élection qui a été volé
c'est une élection avec une victoire
écrasante et tout le monde le sait
surtout nos adversaires mais vous devez
rentrer chez vous maintenant nous devons
être en paix une vidéo retirée par
twitter ainsi que trois publications sur
le même sujet du jamais vu
malgré l'importance de ce conte aux 88
millions d'abonnés en cause aucune
preuve de cette affirmation
comme l'indiquent le réseau social à
plusieurs reprises sur la page de donald
trump en raison de la situation violente
sans précédent et persistante à
washington nous avons exigé le retrait
de 3 tweet du compte de donald trump qui
ont été postées plus tôt dans la journée
pour des violations graves et répétées
de notre politique d'intégrité civique
cela signifie que le compte de donald
trump sera verrouillée pendant douze
heures après la suppression de ces
tweets
si les tweets ne sont pas retirés le
comte restera verrouillé et twitter va
plus loin il menace le président sortant
de suspendre définitivement son compte
toute violation futur des règles de
twitter y compris de nos politiques sur
l'intégrité civique ou les menaces
violentes entraînera la suspension
permanente du comte de donald trump dans
la foulée facebook et youtube emboîtent
le pas à twitter le réseau social et la
plateforme ont eux aussi supprimé la
vidéo contestées c'est une situation
d'urgence et nous prenons des mesures
d'urgence appropriées y compris le
retrait de la vidéo du président trump
nous l'avons retirée parce que tout bien
considéré nous pensons qu'elles
contribuent aux risques de violence au
lieu de le diminuer
ce jeudi facebook a sévi mark zuckerberg
son pdg a annoncé qu'il bloquait le
compte de donald trump
les relations entre le locataire de la
maison blanche et les réseaux sociaux
étaient déjà tendues depuis mai 2019
twitter avait alors commencé à épingler
des messages allant à l'encontre de son
code de conduite
trump l'accusant en retour de censure
avec près de 24 mille tweets en quatre
ans pour la première fois
donald trump eux se retrouvent sans voix
sur la toile et pour en parler nous
sommes avec laurence ferrari professeur
d'histoire contemporaine à l'université
d'arras bonsoir alors cesari merci
d'être avec nous les mesures prises par
les réseaux sociaux contre donald trump
est ce qu elles sont appropriées selon
vous c'est difficile à dire ça dépend de
ce qu'on attend des réseaux sociaux en
droit ce sont de simples messagerie à
ciel ouvert où la communication et est
soumis aux règles de bienséance est
dictée par la cire mais vous en avez
rappelé ne pas inciter à la violence ne
pas répondre aux formations et cetera en
fait les réseaux sociaux sont devenus
des sources d'informations vitales qui
pallie les insuffisances des médias
officiels en gros de thil et les
printemps arabes
donc il ya deux choses si moi j'aurais
tendance à comprendre cette commandite
si je peux si je grandisse il aurait
l'impression que le retrait de trump de
facebook twitter et cetera cette une
censure qui est temps cette politique
andros qu'on pourrait se demander c'est
pour parce que ça fait bien longtemps si
on prend les les règles de bienséance
des réseaux sociaux que trump les arts
les a franchi allègrement
mais sait on est seul on a longtemps été
un bon client comme vous le disiez il a
porté
80 millions d'abonnés est donc là ça me
fait penser un petit tenu à la censure
de mccarthy en 1954 et quand il est allé
trop loin quand il s'en est pris à
l'armée de terre et les livrent les
grands journaux pour lesquels il était
un très bon client si l'on l'ont laissé
tomber
donc là j'ai l'impression que c'est un
retournement ou qui peut choquer dans la
même tâche dans la mesure où
effectivement c'est une censure n'y a
pas de doute là dessus
et inversement la fonction officielle
des réseaux chaude chaude n'est pas
d'être des moyens d'information donc on
a une situation où le souhaitait le
droit sont différents justement marine
le pen a réagi ce matin dans notre homme
doit condamner ce qui s'est passé encore
faut-il qu'ils puissent le faire puisque
sa vidéo d'appels au calme dont on pense
ce qu'on veut et est censuré par les
réseaux sociaux cette censure dit elle
des géants du numérique pose question y
compris en france
quel est votre sentiment par rapport à
cette sortie de marine le pen si des
peut-être dommage de ne pas avoir pu
entendre l'appel au calme de donald
trump hier soir j'ai vu cette vidéo tout
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est une
issue que c'est extrêmement ambigu il y
a du bout des lèvres il appelle au calme
enfin de commandes iran en fin de
message et pour le reste ils passent
leur temps à dire je vous comprends vous
avez raison
donc vous dit la limite la question
n'est pas n'est pas tellement le le le
contenu
le contenu est ambiguë mais tous cas
c'est trump a depuis 2002 puis s'être
depuis des lustres est ambigu il a
constamment utilisé il a constamment
mais les communications privées et
communication publique c'est le seul
gouvernement ou gerland avec erdogan qui
gouvernent par twitter interposé
donc effectivement nous sommes bien dans
une situation
un vénérable à mon avis et qui ne peut
se tromper que par des décisions et non
pas des droits est manifestement comment
dire twitter facebook etc ont choisi le
vainqueur on choisit ont choisi le camp
de baden et de peines ce qui se comprend
de leur lutte
car comme l'a dit le no 3 et récolte
précédente sommes maintenant très isolés
merci beaucoup en tout cas laurent césar
et d'avoir été avec nous restez avec
nous dans quelques instants
elle nous reviendrons sur la conférence
de presse en france 2 jean castex le
gouvernement affiche sa priorité le
vaccin pour espérer sortir de l'épidémie
cet été la circulation du variant
britannique détecté en france reste sous
haute surveillance et puis ce sera les
neet aux échos dans lequel état et notre
économie et jacques sapir et les cours
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça le fond de la politique c'est la
rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs plus qu'à
des réalités ça comme conséquence que la
politique est devenue un métier du
spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique trop de lois tuent la loi et
les lois inutiles thulé vol nwa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu'il avait fini pour moi est ce
que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du mahler mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
[Musique]
21h heure française merci nous rejoindre
pour cette deuxième heure d'émission
tout de suite voici les titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 7 janvier
la priorité numéro un le vaccin martèle
jean castex principale source d'espoir
pour sortir de cette épidémie et le
rythme qui va s'accélérer 600 centres de
vaccination devraient être ouverts à la
fin du mois lieux culturels ou sportifs
bars et restaurants devront encore
patienter
dès demain 10 départements
supplémentaires pourraient voir leur
couvre-feu avancé à 18 heures in fine
est la circulation du variant
britannique sous haute surveillance la
frontière avec le royaume uni restera
fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre après la
récession historique de l'année dernière
précipitée par le cos vides comment se
présente 2021
jusqu'ici l'argent public à limiter la
casse les marchés financiers sont même
au zénith mais dans quel état et
l'économie réelle en ce début d'année
allons-nous rentrer dans le dur de la
crise et prochains mois autant de
questions qu'elle l'économiste jacques
sapir tentera de répondre à beaucoup de
questions au lendemain de l'intrusion
des pros trump au capitole condamné
massivement par la communauté
internationale ces événements n'était-il
pas prévisible at on sous-estimé la
colère d'être homme pis ces violences ne
sont elles pas imputable
car donald trump quid de l'avenir ce
sera l'objet de notre décryptage
[Musique]
le premier ministre jean castex et nos
ministres de la santé olivier vers ans
sont exprimés sur la situation sanitaire
et la stratégie vaccinale tout à l'heure
alors que faut-il retenir de cette
conférence de presse les détails de
quentin mauclair le monde de la
restauration d'euros encore patienter
jean castex a confirmé ce jeudi après
midi que les bars et restaurants ne
pourrons rouvrir leurs portes avant au
minimum le milieu du mois de février
même son de cloche pour les remontées
mécaniques des stations de ski ainsi que
la culture dont les situations seront
réévaluées le 20 janvier
s'agissant du secteur de la culture avec
roselyne bachelot un point de revoyure
début janvier la situation sanitaire que
je viens de vous décrire ne nous permet
malheureusement aucune évolution
aujourd'hui les conditions d'une reprise
à compter de début février seront ainsi
concerter avec les représentants de ces
secteurs que j'ai rencontré à la fin de
la dernière
nous souhaitons leur donner de la
visibilité en travaillant avec eux à
l'élaboration d'une méthode d'ouverture
encadré et progressive à propos du
couvre-feu à 18h10 autres départements
de l'est de la france pourrait être
soumis à cette mesure
une décision sera prise ce vendredi pour
les départements où le couvre-feu est
fixé à 20 heures cette restriction
durera encore deux semaines à minima au
sujet des vaccins
jean castex et oliveira ont tenté
d'éteindre les critiques concernant la
lenteur de la stratégie de l'exécutif
le ministre de la santé a fixé
l'objectif d'un million de personnes
vaccinées à la fin du mois de janvier
le premier ministre estime de son côté
que la vaccination est désormais la
priorité du gouvernement
le déploiement de la vaccination dessine
une perspective claire de pouvoir sortir
progressivement de cette crise sanitaire
à l'échéance nous l'espérons tous de
l'été prochain pour autant nous allons
devoir vivre avec ce virus encore
plusieurs mois
nous ne baisserons donc pas la garde sur
les gestes barrières les tests ou encore
les mesures de freinage
ce serait irresponsable mais la
vaccination est devenue la priorité
numéro 1 de l'action du gouvernement
nous sommes tous convaincus que c'est la
vaccination la plus large la plus
massive et la plus rapide qui nous
permettra de sortir de la crise
si les effets des fêtes de fin d'année
ne seront observés que la semaine
prochaine
l'inquiétude règne autour des deux
nouveaux variants britannique et sud
africain le gouvernement craint que ces
deux formes plus contagieuse du virus ne
se propage dans l'hexagone de clusters
ont d'ailleurs été détecté en bretagne
en ile de france
conséquence la frontière avec le royaume
uni restera fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre
et pour évoquer cette stratégie
vaccinale nous sommes avec christophe
fauvel responsable du centre de
vaccination internationale au chu de
strasbourg bonsoir christophe romaine
merci d'être avec nous alors on l'a
compris en priorité affichée au vaccin
mais surtout accélération après la salle
de critique comment vous accueillez vous
voulez les propos du premier ministre ce
soir après ce démarrage lent mais assumé
par le gouvernement
je suis tout à fait en faveur de cette
accélération de la campagne de
vaccination
on n'a pas attendu les déclarations
d'aujourd'hui puisque c'est en fait
depuis le début de la semaine qu'on
s'est attelé à mettre en place
rapidement des centres de vaccination au
sein des établissements pour les agents
hospitaliers et dans d'autres structures
comme la mienne pour les professionnels
de santé en dehors des pour les
prochaines de santé libéraux justement
là où vous êtes à strasbourg au chu
comment ça se passe concrètement est ce
que vous les avez ces doses de vaccins
déjà
oui nous avons ces vaccins depuis la
semaine du 27 décembre puisque la
campagne de vaccination devrait
commencer pour les seniors dans les
ehpad dans ces vaccins nous les avions
déjà et l'hôpital le chu et livrés
régulièrement au niveau des vaccins la
semaine dernière on donnera cette
semaine on aura normalement toutes les
semaines une livraison puisque chu va
délivrer du vaccin sur l'ensemble des
établissements de la de l'alsace en
tulle du bas rhin en tout cas au pardon
alors jean castex a annoncé des
objectifs clairs ce soir déjà il a dit
qu 45000 personnes avaient été vaccinées
hier un million d'ici à la fin janvier
avec les plus de 75 ans à partir du 18
janvier cela vous semble crédible d
objectif tenable selon vous
aujourd'hui c'est bien d'avoir des
objectifs on va se donner tous les
moyens pour y arriver les choses vont
aller plus ou moins a progressivement
mais on et off les plages dans lesquels
on propose la vaccination des structures
vont s'ouvrir plus intensément et donc
ça permettra d'accueillir effectivement
plus en plus de monde
alors on l'espère en tout cas pour vous
autres annonces au d'olivier veron et
pas des moindres la deuxième dose de
faiseur ventech qui peut être différée
injuste qu'un je cite six semaines au
lieu de trois ans on sait que d'autres
pays ont fait ce choix le royaume-uni le
danemark mais à quels impératifs répond
peut-il vraiment est-ce que vous en tant
que médecin vous fait confiance en ce
procédé qui on va pas se mentir et
peut-être une option choisie pour aller
beaucoup plus vite finalement faute de
doses indisponible alors si on suit les
les décisions britannique soit c'est
pragmatique et ils l'ont déjà montré par
pour d'autres vaccinations par ailleurs
et ils ont souvent eu raison je pense
que les données le suivi des données
d'étude sur les vaccins permettront de
dire si on peut effectivement espaces et
c'est le même principe que toute dose de
notre vaccin
on sait que si on fait une première dose
et qui a une deuxième dose même si celle
ci arrive un peu plus tard le système
immunitaire permet d'y répondre donc ça
je pense que les données scientifiques
permettront de de dire qu'effectivement
on pourra espacées et ce qui serait une
bonne chose et une bonne nouvelle
puisque en ce cas là on permettrait de
vacciner bien plus de monde
sachant qu'on pourrait étaler la
deuxième dose plus tardivement vos
voisins allemands vous n'êtes pas
vraiment loin de la frontière allemande
se plainent déjà d'être en pénurie de
vaccins est ce que c'est quelque chose
auquel on fera forcément face en france
alors oui et non je comprends je vois la
situation en allemagne puisque ils ont
été près quelque peu avant nous puisque
fin novembre début décembre était déjà
dans les starting blocks qu'ils
attendaient plus que les vaccins ils ont
mis en place des grosses structures de
l'oxydation et qui fait qu'ils ont
peut-être pu vacciner plus rapidement un
grand nombre de personnes mais la
livraison des vaccins n'a pas été plus
importante pour autant est ce qui fait
qu ils peuvent se retrouver aujourd'hui
effectivement pour certains centres
fermés faute de vaccins mais je crois
qu'en israël ils ont vécu la même chose
là elles étant le pays le plus avancé
sur la couverture vaccinale est donc ils
ont tellement vite rapidement vacciner
que pour l'instant ils sont un peu
bloquée faute de vaccins disponibles en
tout cas l'europe pourra compter sur un
nouveau vaccin moderna qui a été
homologué un par l'autorité de santé
européennes
c'est une bonne chose cette
diversification de vaccin parce que
c'est vrai que quand on est français
qu'on n'y connais pas grand chose au
liban est ce qu'on va pouvoir choisir
entre tel ou tel vaccin on nous dit que
certains sont plus efficaces que
d'autres que certains pourraient être
entre guillemets voilà plus pas plus
dangereux mais en tout cas partie des
français le pont simple puisque plus
moderne et moins connus alors juste pour
revenir peut-être sur votre question
précédente ça répondra aussi à celle là
c'est que en france est ce qu'on aura
une pénurie
avec humour je dirais que non puisque si
50 ou plus 2% des les français ne
veulent pas se faire vacciner
ils vont rester comment je pouvais dire
qu'on ne manquera pas de vaccin pour
ceux qui espèrent se faire vacciner mais
ça c'est un autre problème
l'arrivée du deuxième vaccin c'est une
excellente chose aussi c'est que ça
permet aussi d'augmenter
enfin la possibilité de vacciner plus de
monde alors les deux premiers pas les
airs et moderna sont les vaccins de même
nature sont des vaccins arn messager
donc ça ne changera pas foncièrement les
choses après on attendra celui
d'astrazeneca
et puis effectivement lorsqu'on aura 4 5
vaccin à disposition
en fait c'est l'indication du vaccin que
choisira le médecin selon les personnes
qui pourraient être retenues vous
fassiez l'usure assez sceptique nombreux
on a vu encore voilà un représentant
louis fouchet dans ce débat quel est
votre sentiment quand vous les entendez
parce que il faut voilà et vous le savez
mieux que personne il faut savoir que
c'est aujourd'hui près de la moitié de
la population
france a tout de même alors on peut
comprendre le questionnement et c'est
tout à fait normal de se questionner sur
des problématiques scientifiques sur des
médicaments dont on ne comprend pas le
fonctionnement ou comment ça a pu être
développé aussi rapidement et c'est bien
notre rôle nous médecins professionnels
répondre à ces questions puisque nous
lisons les données scientifiques les
publications et on se fait un avis tout
à fait clair sur la vaccination qui est
tout à fait utile qui a montré son
efficacité et son innocuité donc on est
là pour répondre donc le questionnement
des gens effectivement on peut tout à
fait le comprendre et on doit répondre à
ces questionnements
après il ya tout eu 10 faire de
population qui est drôle
les thématiques du complot et etc et qui
sont un peu victimes de toutes les
informations qui circulent sur la
vaccination est il est vrai aussi que
les français sont un peu champions
malheureusement champion du monde pour
cette réticence à la vaccination c'est
une histoire très ancienne dans le pays
ce qui est un peu paradoxal dans le pays
de pasteur mais c'est un fait tout à
fait établi
donc il faut peut-être un peu plus de
temps pour arriver à expliquer aux gens
et à leschères amené à prendre une
position pro thaksin
merci beaucoup christophe aubel d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france ce
soir est dans l'actualité accès à la
récession historique de l'an dernier et
précipitée par le cos vides comment se
présente 2021 jusqu'ici la mise sous
perfusion d'argent public de nos
économies
elle limiter la casse évidemment les
marchés financiers sont même au zénith
mais dans quel état et l'économie réelle
en ce début d'année
allons nous entrer dans le dur de la
crise ces prochains mois on en parle
tout de suite avec l'économiste jacques
sapir bonsoir et voilà bonsoir jacquet
bonne année à vous puisque voilà c'est
le premier édito écho depuis de 21 et
bien jacques on parle beaucoup du monde
d'après
la pandémie quelles seront donc les
conséquences de cette dernière
cette année elles seront évidemment
extrêmement importante vous savez pour
la france d'abord dont on voit bien que
l'avenir économique ne s'éclaire a pas
avant cet été pour l'europe ensuite un
qui va prendre avec cette pandémie
semble craindre un retard économique
tout à fait considérable et enfin pour
le monde parce que effectivement on voit
que les équilibres économiques vont
bouger de manière extrêmement importante
alors voyons donc la france jacques de
quoi seront faits les prochains mois
voire les prochaines années stéphanie je
vous mentirais si je disais que les
perspectives sont bonnes à la deuxième
vague de la pandémie est venu ajouter
son poids au fardeau économique que l'on
pouvait d'ailleurs calculé depuis le
moins d'octobre dernier s'est en
particulier ceux qui avaient fait le
fonds monétaire international
le deuxième confinement un début d'année
qui risque d'être chaotique encore au
moins jusqu'à la fin du printemps vont
retarder la récupération de l'économie
le fmi avait calculé que l'on
retrouverait le niveau de 2019 au
printemps 2003 petit ospreys et bien il
faudra très probablement atteindre la
fin de 2004 voire le début de 2025
pour atteindre cet objectif alors c'est
à dire jacques que 2021 va marquer
l'entraînant dans le dur de la crise en
france est tout d'abord quel rebond pour
les d'économies oui là c'est fini vous
avez là encore tout à fait raison on
sait que dans le cours de 2021 les aides
gouvernementales vont progressivement
s'arrêter c'est d'ailleurs tout à fait
normal mais c'est à ce moment là que
nous allons découvrir à quel point le
pays s'est appauvri durant la crise
alors cette improvisation
appauvrissement excusez moi on peut
chercher à le calculer et si on rapporte
ça en milliards par rapport au pib de
eh bien on voit que les pertes calculé
début octobre donc avant la deuxième
vague se monte déjà à peu près 3
milliards à l'horizon 2024 avec les
conséquences économiques de la deuxième
vague
on pourrait atteindre 2 420 à 650
milliards d'euros autrement dit entre un
sixième et un quart de la valeur du pipe
de 2002 2019 alors avec quelles
conséquences pour les français oui si le
pays s'appauvrit évidemment les français
vont s'appauvrir
mais certains vont malheureusement ça
d'ouvrir bien plus que d'autres
il ya déjà 10 millions de personnes qui
sont sous le seuil de pauvreté
et on peut penser que cela devrait
augmenter dans les mois qui viennent
deux catégories de français vont être le
plus touché ça il faut en est il faut en
être absolument persuadé ce sont d'abord
les salariés à faible qualification est
en prêt les travailleurs indépendants
qui sont bien entendu les grandes
victimes déconfinement notre pays va
mettre des années à se remettre du choc
de la pandémie et c'est donc en 2021 que
l'on va malheureusement rentrer dans le
dur de la crise alors malgré cela
jacques les marchés boursiers eux exulte
mais dans le détail tout va finalement
passer bien non non assurément stéphanie
est clairement le décalage entre la
sphère financière et l'économie réelle
résulte des injections de liquidités des
banques centrales
bon il ya aussi un décalage entre les
secteurs économiques
parmi les plus sinistrées il ya
évidemment les industries aéronautique
et le tourisme vous savez pour les
industries aéronautiques
l'iata l'association internationale du
transport aérien estime que le transport
aérien c'est qu'on s'est contracté des
deux tiers il vient les deux tiers en
2020 et qu'en 2021 son activité devrait
n'être encore que grosso modo de 60% par
rapport à ce qu'elle était en 2019 il
faudra donc atteindre de 2024 à 2026
pour retrouver le nombre de passagers
transportés en 2010 9 dans le meilleur
des cas et on est très bien toutes les
conséquences que cela aura sur des
industries comme airbus mais aussi
évidemment sur les services associés qui
seront et ses conséquences seront très
profonde
inversement
les activités pharmaceutiques mais aussi
les activités qui sont liées à
l'internet comme le e-commerce et les
activités des plateformes de films qui
propose des visites virtuelles de musées
par exemple il ya tout cela ça s'est
fortement développée mais se sont il
faut le savoir aussi des activités qui
crée relativement peu d'emplois c'est
qu'ils ont devra craindre une très forte
montée du chômage dans les mois qui
viennent avons nous disait aussi qu'il y
aurait des conséquences sur l'europe
oui oui absolument et on voit bien que
la pandémie
elle accentue aujourd'hui la division
entre deux groupes de pays d'un côté
évidemment les pays de l'europe du nord
en particulier l'allemagne qui résiste
plutôt mieux 20 avec bien entendu leurs
problèmes et d'un autre côté les pays de
l'europe du sud de l'italie l'espagne et
la france dont les problèmes vont
s'aggraver alors ces pays ont déjà payé
très cher la désindustrialisation imposé
par les règles européennes et par les
effets de l'euro ces dernières années et
là on doit bien qu'il faudra un
pivotement de leur stratégie qui va
devoir s'imposer très rapidement
maintenant alors jacques vous avez
également parlé de changements à
l'échelle mondiale oui tout à fait c'est
famille et c'est sans doute le plus
significatif en ce qui concerne le monde
d'après et lakovic 19
on constate que la croissance de la zone
euro et on le voit sur le graphique sera
très inférieure à celle des pays du g7
évidemment mais aussi des autres pays
développés et même très inférieur aux
pays émergents en particulier des pays
émergents d'asie dont au premier chef la
chine l'économie du monde d'après
l'académie s'écrira sans la zone euro
sans l'union européenne et nous verrons
aussi c'est un point important ce
accélérer le déclin américain alors que
la chine elle va s'affirmer comme l'une
de puissance économique mondiale une
puissance central dans l'économie
mondiale s'est très certainement la
leçon la plus importante que l'on peut
tirer de la crise actuelle alors en
conclusion jacques ce sont donc des
perspectives plutôt sombres pour nous
européens et pour les français en
particulier
et oui c'était là cela stéphanie les
ratés au démarrage de la campagne de
vaccination en france sont de ce point
de vue là très symptomatique
mais il faut savoir que même si cette
campagne avait été correctement géré
même si elle avait bien démarré on ne
doit pas s'attendre à des effets
significatifs sur l'économie je voulais
dit avant le début de l'été 2021 et
d'ici là évidemment et les problèmes
vont s'aggraver
la france et plus globalement les pays
de l'union européenne et de la zone euro
sont englués dans des politiques
économiques qui se révèle aujourd'hui
avec la crise de lakovic 19 absolument
suicidaire il le paye très cher et il
risque de le payer encore plus cher dans
les mois qui viennent et bien jacques
merci merci on va dire mais bon on a pas
très réjouissant en tout cas ces
nouvelles et à la semaine prochaine avec
on l'espère quand même de meilleures
nouvelles jacques excellente soirée et
une crise qui continue d'avoir des
conséquences dramatiques sur l'économie
et l'emploi en france à l'instar de ce
que nous disait jacques saint-pierre à
l'instant les faillites d'entreprises
pourrait détruire et détruire jusqu'à
deux cent mille postes selon les
projections de la fcpe
chez michelin plusieurs
post 2 milles environ seront supprimés
d'ici trois ans mais le groupe entend
développer de nouvelles activités et re
créer d'autres emplois les détails avec
solène gaudin 2300 postes sur 21 mille
en france d'ici trois ans michelin
entend supprimer plus de 10 % de ses
emplois
mais pas de départ contraint selon la
direction pas de fermeture d'usiné
aucun départ contraint nous anticipons
environ 60% de mesures de préretraite et
40% de départs volontaires dans le cadre
de rupture conventionnelle collective
face à la concurrence des pneus à prix
cassés
michelin tente de rebondir objectif
investir dans des secteurs d'avenir
hydrogène impression 3d ou encore
recyclage des déchets plastiques d'ici à
l'entreprise souhaite que 30% de son
chiffre d'affaires soit réalisé en
dehors de l'industrie du pneu des
activités grâce auquel le fabricant
français promet de recréer autant
d'emplois qu'il en aura supprimé mais
l'activité initiale du groupe concerne
15 sites en france l'annnonce de
suppressions de postes inquiète les
syndicats
il y aura des négociations mais c'est
comme un plan de sauvegarde de l'emploi
sans licenciement la première année il y
aura des volontaires mais après on
connaît la méthode michelin pour en
fabriquer ce seront des volontaires par
dépit de son côté le gouvernement promet
d'être attentif aux promesses de
michelin avec les représentants du
personnel
nous serons particulièrement vigilants à
ce que michelin respecte ses engagements
depuis 2010 est l'entreprise a déjà
supprimé 1500 postes dans le cadre de sa
réorganisation notamment au siège
historique de clermont ferrand et aux
états unis
michelin dit avoir retardé cette
nouvelle réduction d'effectifs à cause
de la crise sanitaire
depuis le début de la pandémie de covile
19 et le premier confinement en france
les annonces de plans sociaux et de
fermetures de sites industriels se
multiplient renault auchan bridgestone
airbus bénéteau camaïeu ou encore
nextradiotv
aucun secteur ne semble épargner prêt
dans quelques instants rester avec nous
nous reviendrons sur l' inverse
du capitole hier la sidération passé
comment en est on arrivé là
at on sous-estimé la colère des
partisans de trump ce sera l'objet de
notre décryptage
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçon il est l'âme on les
a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croatie donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productif
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue là emmanuel macron
n'a rien changé par exemple par rapport
à son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système aux
tourtes à dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions de réformes
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous parlerons de tout sans langue de
bois
[Musique]
quelle image il laisse de lui diego
maradona en argentine il laisse une
image bas d'une icône absolue d'un dieu
vivant parce que il a porté très haut
les couleurs d'un pays qui était
humiliée par la guerre des malouines se
plie à gagner la coupe du monde alors
c'est pas une victoire militaire mais
c'est une revanche politique et sportif
sur une défaite militaire pas ce qu'est
la politique et le sport font finalement
bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique
c'était un homme d'ultragauche on
connaît sa proximité avec castro on
connaît sa proximité avec hugo chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central
vous êtes encore en train de dire
finalement diego maradona c'est l'homme
du passé ce cap a un côté paradoxal le
moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que le
personnage n'est pas lisse et qui est
multiple aspérités et c'est pour ça que
c'est un personnage de légende
[Musique]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers ce
sont avant tout des commerçants ils ont
négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économie globale
qui crée la plus grande zone de libre
échange du monde
l'annnonce de sa signature par vidéo à
hanoi bouleverse les équilibres mondiaux
et consacre la perte d'influencé
américaine dans cette partie goût il est
clair qu'avec cet accord le pôle
économique mondiale tant au niveau du
développement que de l'interactivité est
dorénavant durablement installé sur le
continent asiatique avec son épicentre
en rendez vous compte un espace
économique occupé par 2 milliards 200
millions d'habitants qui représente 30%
de la production mondiale de richesse
il est triste et même inquiétant de
constater que l'europe se retrouve
aujourd'hui marginalisée par rapport à
l'air super
[Musique]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
je suis l'ex maire et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
la chasse est un lobby donc il pèse très
lourd il faut arrêter de dire que on a
besoin des chasseurs qu'on a besoin de
régulation on n'a jamais eu la preuve de
ça cette réduction du débat justement
entre le tout blanc a le tout noir ne
nuit-elle pas finalement à l'idée même
que les français pour espère de la
chasse je crois pas que ce soit réduire
le débat bhl de rappeler que c'est un
plaisir qui va jusqu'à la mort cc c'est
ça l'essentiel et c'est pour ça que
c'est un sujet très très épidermique
parce que s'ils une histoire de vie et
de mort il faut protéger la végétation
pour protéger la faune il faut protéger
notre santé
tout ça c'est y est n'oublions pas tous
nos problèmes viennent du mépris qu'on a
sur le reste du monde vivant donc il
faut il faut arrêter de laisser les
chasseurs faire leur bêtise et je suis
poli
[Musique]
21h30 heure française soyez les
bienvenus en direct du rt france si vous
nous rejoignez direction washington au
lendemain des événements qui se sont
produits au capitole au lieu de la
démocratie américaine quatre personnes
ont perdu la vie lors de ces violences
pour nancy pelosi des maîtres donald
trump et joe site une urgence de la plus
haute importance ce dernier qui pour la
première fois parle d'une transition
ordonnée les prévisions des précisions
de taille raid nature à un présentateur
d' rtm erika nous sommes tous que robbie
après ces événements c'est le maintien
qui me pris place dans notre capitale
c'était inattendu c'était effrayant
et c'est une insulte pour ceux que notre
pays représente la transition tout fassi
fiq
cela nous rappelle presque des actions
que nous avons menées dans d'autres pays
dans le monde entier
lorsque nous avons poussé en avant des
transitions difficiles et voir cela sur
notre propre territoire c'était vraiment
un choc car cela aurait été très
facilement évitables complètement isolé
il ya même des rumeurs qu'on ferait
jouer le 25e amendement qui leur époque
fait pour une incapacité à gouverner
pour difficultés mentales
à peine deux semaines de la transition
de pouvoir verdure beit-el on le 20
janvier joe biden est très isolé même au
sein de ce parti des membres de son
cabinet démissionne alors que le navire
coule et sera très intéressant de voir
ce qui va arriver au cours des jours à
venir
le 25ème à
comment sera-t-il invoqué pour révoquer
de nacre et le week-end ce sera alors au
pouvoir ne le savons pas ce qui va
arriver mais l'armée retour en tous cas
dans le voisinage et la situation très
difficile pour donald trump
les images de l'intrusion des pros trump
ont fait le tour du monde avec des
policiers obligés de dégainer leur arme
dans le capitole pour protéger les élus
du gaz lacrymogène a été utilisé dans la
rotonde du capitole du capitole retour
sur les images fortes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi
[Applaudissements]
à
le
à vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais ces événements ont fait vivement
réagir l'ensemble de la communauté
internationale et si tous ont condamné
la violence des faits certains pays en
ont profité pour faire part d'un esprit
de revanche face aux agissements passés
des états unis en voyant les images
impressionnantes de cette foule aux
abords et à l'intérieur du capitole vous
pouvez avoir deux types de réactions
quand vous êtes un responsable politique
d'ailleurs les communiqués et autres
réactions envoyer ses dernières heures
en témoigne après avoir condamné
fermement les violences la suite de
votre message dépend de vos relations
avec washington
voyons d'abord les alliés historiques
des états unis quand dans une des plus
vieilles démocraties du monde
des partisans d'un président sortant
remettre en cause par les armes
les résultats légitimes d'une élection
c'est une idée universelle celle d'un
homme une voix qui est battue en brèche
je suis avec beaucoup d'inquiétude ce
qui se passe à washington
la violence est incompatible avec
l'exercice des droits politiques et des
libertés démocratiques
j'ai confiance dans la solidité et la
force des institutions des états unis je
crois en la force des institutions et de
la démocratie américaine
la transition pacifique du pouvoir est
essentiel joe biden a remporté
l'élection
ton grave et soutien sans faille aux
valeurs américaines
emmanuel macron a même placé un drapeau
américain derrière lui pour son
allocution
mais tous les pays ne font pas preuve de
la même compassion certains dirigeants
internationaux ont sauté sur l'occasion
pour se rappeler au bon souvenir d'une
diplomatie américaine si prompte à
l'ingérence dans les processus
électoraux d'autres pays ce qu'on a vu
la nuit dernière et aujourd'hui en
amérique ou d'abord à quel point la
démocratie occidentale est un échec et à
quel point ces fondations sont
bhl est fragile le venezuela condamne la
polarisation politique et la spirale de
violence qui ne reflète que la crise
profonde que traverse actuellement le
système politique et sociale des états
unis avec cet épisode malheureux les
états unis souffrent de ce qu'ils ont
généré dans d'autres pays avec leur
politique agressive
une manière d'ironiser pour caracas pays
où la tentative de coup d'état par wang
wei d'eau en mai 2010 neuf avaient pour
beaucoup étaient très fortement soutenu
par washington
alors comment aurait réagi la diplomatie
américaine si ces images du capitole
s'étaient déroulées ailleurs sur la
planète
en tout cas voici celle relative à
washington hier soir en provenance de
l'ancien président américain george w
bush
c'est un spectacle écoeurant et
déchirant c'est comme cela que les
résultats d'une élection sont disputés
dans une république bananière pas dans
notre démocratie républicaine et si les
réactions varient selon les relations
diplomatiques entre les pays la
qualification attribué peut également
changer selon l'intérêt qu'un état peut
trouver un à soutenir un mouvement de
contestation un double discours que n'a
pas manqué de souligner pékin les médias
mainstream aux états unis ont
unanimement condamné cela comme un
incident violent en utilisant des mots
tels que bandits extrémistes traître et
ont dû cependant quels mots ont-ils
utilisé pour décrire les manifestants
violents à hong kong
il disait que c'était un beau spectacle
est présenté les manifestants violents
comme des héros ce démocratique et que
le peuple américain les soutenait je
pense que nous devrions réfléchir
attentivement à la raison derrière ce
contraste concernant l'attitude des
états unis entre ce qu'il s'est passé à
hong kong en 2019
est ce qu'il se passe aux etats unis
aujourd'hui la partialité des médias
américains c'est aussi ce que souligne
la diplomatie russe moscou en profite
pour remettre en cause le mode de
scrutin américain c'est une affaire
interne des états unis en même temps
nous attirons à nouveau l'attention sur
le fait que le système électoral et
archaïque aux états unis qu'ils ne
répondent pas aux normes démocratiques
modernes ce qui rend possible de
nombreuses violations et que les médias
américains sont devenus un outil de
lutte politique
la preuve que si
laissera des traces dans l'histoire
politique américaine la journée du 6
janvier 2021 pour être aussi faire date
en termes de diplomatie dans le monde
des réactions sont donc nombreuses
dernière en date ce soir une nouvelle
réaction du mythe premier ministre
britannique boris johnson qui a condamné
sans réserve l'attitude du président
américain donald trump au jeu site avoir
encouragé les violences perpétrées par
ses sympathisants au capitole siège du
congrès américain de bagdad à moscou la
plupart des personnes interrogées
dénonce les scènes de violence ce qu'il
s'est passé hier au congrès américain
est une émanation total de la démocratie
ils prétendent qu'ils ont la démocratie
pour leur propre peuple mais
j'appellerai cela une fausse démocratie
parce qu'elle n'existe pas et qu'elle
est tout à fait artificielle
les essais seulement de donner une image
déformée des pays arabes en disant que
ceux ci ne sont ni développé ni organisé
je regardais ça hier soir comme tous les
états lien partout dans le monde
j'ai vu ces images terribles que
personne ne s'attendait à voir sur la
colline du capitole à washington
et puis entendre l'actuel président des
états unis
qualifié ces gens de spéciaux est tout
aussi grave parce que c'est lui qui les
a encouragés et ensuite les a presque
défendu dingue
les états unis donc
c'est c'est dans l'ordre des choses sont
un peu dingue et ils réagissent de façon
excessive
dans tous les cas de figure d'une
manière générale trump et un excessif
bon
on peut redouter jusqu'à quel point ça
peut aller qu'en des populistes arrivent
au pouvoir ils font de telles choses et
oui cela ne devrait jamais arriver
vous savez qu aux etats unis la
démocratie a une longue histoire et
quand on arrive à quelque chose comme ça
oui on a peur cela a l'air assez
ridicule il faut savoir reconnaître sa
défaite à temps il se comporte comme un
rat qui est expulsé de la maison il
revient et vous le voyez les réactions
restent nombreuses images de chaos hier
à washington mais la sidération passé la
question comment on en est arrivé là ton
sous-estimé la colère des partisans de
donald trump qui se sont peut être
parfois sentis méprisés place à notre
décryptage avec nos invités tri pour en
parler nous sommes avec paul rim
présidents des rup bricks and in france
bonsoir paris merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés jean-claude beaujour vice
président du cercle de réflexion
france-amérique avocat en droit
international également
bonsoir à vous est également jean-claude
beaujour on l'a vu un ces images en ont
créé une onde de choc dans la classe
politique américaine condamnations
unanimes y compris dans votre parti à
paris nains les républicains je vous
propose avant vous faire réagir d'écouté
mitt romney un ancien candidat que vous
connaissez évidemment des républicains à
l'élection présidentielle de 2012 ce qui
s'est passé ici aujourd'hui est une
insurrection provoqué par le président
des états unis
ceux qui choisissent de continuer à
soutenir son dangereux stratagème en
s'opposant aux résultats d'une élection
légitime et démocratique seront à jamais
considéré comme complice d'une attaque
sans précédent contre notre démocratie
voilà des propos assez clair en demies
turn et qui ne soutient pas donald trump
pèlerine quand vous avez
et vu ces images qu est ce que vous avez
ressenti y est est-ce que vous soutenez
toujours avec autant de ferveur donald
trump ce soir c'est pas les bons images
ça c'est sûr c'est l'image présente
nous condamnons un trou de violence dans
les thèmes toutefois possible et toute
évidence le pâtis du public un devis
lancée contre les principes de la partie
du public et on a toujours comme dans
une violence qui étaient dans les rues
par les gauchistes en fait pendant le
dernier 9 12 mois et en condamnant très
fort cette violence aussi par les
républicains et c'est pas bon
ils ont forcé l'entrée dans le capital
et c'est vraiment pas bien
c'est tout ce que je peux dire là alors
on se pose évidemment beaucoup de
questions à 24 heures après ces
violences pourquoi on en est arrivé là
les militants pro trump est ce qu'on a
sous-estimé leur colère avant de vous
faire réagir à vos aussi jean-claude
bonjour je vous propose d'écouter ces
manifestants trump est un leader il
défend le monde libre il défend nous
droit et si j'étais à sa place je ferais
la même chose je sens que j'étais censé
être ici alors on est allé à l'intérieur
parce que je crois que dieu voulait que
j'y sois
elle est venue pour soutenir maman nous
exigeons que les élections soient
intègres et nous pensons que le
président train à gagner et nous
n'allons pas seulement dire et accepter
la tricherie
nous devons envoyer un message au
congrès nous voulons reprendre le pays
c'est notre maison ils ont essayé de
barricader les gens ils ont fait tomber
la barricade comme des kurdes en actes
elles sont éparpillées partout et
maintenant nous reprenons notre pays
je suis convaincu que trucks a
réellement gagné l'élection et qu'il y a
eu suffisamment de tricherie et de
fraudes qui ont été balayés qu'un qu'ils
ne veulent pas en entendre parler
huawei l'avion juste arrêter ce vol de
l'élection one step champion bonjour
c'est important d'écouter ces
témoignages parce que on touche
peut-être le fond de ce problème en tout
cas c'est que de nombreux militants pro
trump sont convaincus qu'on leur a volé
leur victoire ils sont convaincus qu'il
ya eu tricherie
qu'est ce que vous répondez justement
quand on entend ces témoignages est ce
que vous comprenez un tout petit peu
mieux ce qui s'est passé hier soir vous
j'entends j'entends le témoignage de ces
personnes il est particulièrement
difficile d'argumenter sur le plan
résonner au raisonnable lorsque quelques
vous dis je suis convaincu parce qu'il
m'est difficile d'apporter la preuve
contraire précisément parce que la
question n'est pas d'apporter la preuve
que l'élection s'est bien passé lorsque
dans ce système et je vais vous dire il
n'y a pas qu'aux états unis où il ya des
problèmes lors de scrutins électoraux
il existe aussi y compris en france
lorsque vous avez des problèmes sur des
scrutins électoraux vous porter ces
sujets devant les tribunaux et en tant
qu'avocat et praticiens il y à une
mécanique assez simple vous apportez vos
éléments de preuve
les juges examinent les éléments de
preuve recevables que vous avez et ils
apprécient le point suivant est ce que
lorsqu'il y a des éléments non cocordan
dans le respect de la procédure
on peut même imaginer une éventuelle
fraude
juge apprécie si ces fraudes sont de
nature circonscription par
circonscription où étape par étape donc
circonscriptions électorales par
circonscription électorale
si c'est ces irrégularités ont pu
impacter le résultat définitif du
scrutin et donc donald trump et j'étais
le premier à dire sur vos plateaux que
le président avait le droit de contester
les élections dans les squats dans l'est
des états pour lesquels dans lesquelles
il estimait qu'il y avait un souci il
appartenait aux juges aux tribunaux de
trancher
c'est ce qu'il a fait et les tribunaux
en tranchée en démocratie on ne peut pas
se contenter chacun ne peut pas se
contenter et cela je le dirai que ce
soit un candidat républicain candidat
démocrate ou quel que soit le pays
on ne peut pas se contenter sur une
procédure de dire je crois où j'ai une
conviction alors malheureusement pour
cette personne en démocratie dans nos
systèmes
il y à il y à des tribunaux les dossiers
ont été portés et examinées par les
tribunaux il y a eu plus de 60 procédure
elles ont échoué il faute à un moment
donné on reconnaître les décisions qui
ont été rendus je voudrais vous préciser
que cette question je ne l'avais posé il
y a quelques années au vice-président
trump je leur ai dit monsieur vie serait
donc comment est-ce que coke comment
avez vous réagi lorsque vous avez
réalisé ou lorsque vous avez dû du admet
que vous alliez perdre les élections
vous les aviez perdu du fait de ce
problème en floride et qu'effectivement
des tribunaux vous avez n'avait pas
autorisé à ce que le processus aille
aille au delà il m'a dit elle chose
suivante
à un moment donné il faut savoir
s'arrêter parce qu'il y va de l'avenir
de notre pays et à al gore effectivement
al gore aux bruits des ballerines
nous on parlait hier avec gérald olivier
à un spécialiste des états unis
journalistes qui nous disait mémé ses
militants c'est vrai qu'ils ont été
méprisés souvent pas écouté alors ça
n'excuse pas mais est ce que c'est un
début d'explication à cette colère selon
vous même méprisé excusez moi vous
pouvez spécifier ça oui ça veut dire
qu'ils n'ont pas été considérés écoutez
et et notamment dans les médias
américains c'était en tout cas l'analyse
d'hier de gerald de olivier qui a porté
peut-être un autre son de cloche chez un
début de lecture à ces événements oui le
problème une raison pour le colère et
qu' il y avait beaucoup du tribunal qui
y compris les courses prince qui n'a pas
accepté le cas ligue 1 présenté par par
l'équipe
les gars de 30 donc on croit qu' il
n'avait pas l'opportunité à présenter
toutes les évidences et il ya 400 de
tous les américains qui croient que
l'élection était fendue l'on y compris
10 après son dédain en quarts à temps
il ya une raison pour pour avoir plus d
audit plus des discussions plus des
décisions par les tribunes à la cour
suprême comme dans le cas de 2000 et
avec al gore qui ne qui n'était pas se
passer donc les gens tu es vraiment en
colère et en mon avis justifiée et il
paraît pas il faut pas oublier que les
choses qui en comme dans en condamnant
la violence se tue à la capitale mais
les choses que peu nul et vie publique
un envoi une double standard complète à
part médias et par les démocrates
on oublie que le lendemain d'une
élection de 2016
avec les manifestations virons dans tous
les bons villes aux états unis il n'a
jamais accepté que tu en petit président
et pendant les dernières tulasne et 2020
et avait les émeutes et les violences
complète et les 700 policiers au petit
dans les hôpitaux 35 gens tués et
toujours 2018
il y avait des démocrates donc sur les
escaliers de capital qu'ils ont occupé
les bureaux pendant la confirmation de
ben barka maintenant il
pardonnez-moi ballerines parce que c'est
un débat et les ouïes jean claude
bourgeois aléas les six mois je voudrais
je pense que là il ya il ya eu des
compréhensions que des partisans
manifestent c'est leur droit il y à une
disposition constitue constitutionnelle
américaine qui consacre le droit le
droit à l'opinion le droit d'expression
cela n'est pas contestée là où il faut
qu'on se comprenne très bien c'est que
vous parliez de la cour suprême mais la
cour suprême
ce sont des magistrats qui sont
chevronnés la cour suprême le président
de 30 a nommé trois magistrats de sa
tendance politique y compris la dernière
nomination donc il a une majorité à cour
suprême savez je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faut ne pas simplement se fier
et je vous le dis sincèrement comme
avocat est aussi comme homme engagé
engagé en faveur de l'état de droit
on ne peut pas diriger un pays on ne
peut pas avoir des structures où les
gens ont le sentiment
moi je vais vous dire ce qui m'a choqué
ou du moins ce qui m'a surpris lorsque
j'ai vu que l'avocat du président trump
mon confrère giuliani a présenté un
dossier quand il est apparu quelques
heures après quand il a décidé qu'il
allait
engager des poursuites en toute
franchise le dossier était pauvre c'est
à dire que je n'aurais même pas permis
un collaborateur de présenter un dossier
aussi mal construit il a laissé son
client quand j'ai écouté le président
trump défendre son point et moi
j'entends celui nous avons l'habitude
quant au devant des tribunaux d'entendre
des partis on se tait quand on entend ce
que c'est le principe du contradictoire
on entend toujours ce que dit une partie
on se tait on les écoute lorsque j'ai
entendu le président trump mai mais je
n'ai entendu comme un justiciable je me
suis dit mais pourquoi est ce que son
avocat n'a pas défendu son dossier parce
que c'était mal construit c'est
juridiquement ça n'était pas bien
construit et ça ça n'est pas la faute
des démocrates
il appartenait à vos avocats de
présenter en tout cas dans ce que j'ai
entendu et j'ai lu certain nombre de
décisions
il appartenait à avaux avocats de
rapporter les preuves de d'être plus
construit moi si je vous dise que quand
j'ai entendu le président trump alors
peut-être que la population le coin la
population l'a cru mais on ne fait pas
un dossier à partir du 10 3 ont fait un
dossier à partir de pièces et d'une
démonstration qui est parfois même un
peu mathématiques et je peux vous dire
qu'en la matière la démonstration doit
être mathématiques donc malheureusement
je jantes en alliage de france
ballerines ballerines aujourd'hui
vous êtes un républicain orphelins
est-ce que donald trump n'a pas tout
perdu finalement dans cette affaire ça
sera ma dernière question une bo de la
fin pour vous est-ce qu'il a tout perdu
non je suis hors jeu venant oui ah oui
on est un peu quand ils ont un enfant
mais ok c'est fini on va fait une
transition ordonnée
maintenant le moment que avec tous vos
entretiens avec les gens ont tout le
monde le moment que deux chambres est
passé il est parti et le monde n'a pas
quelqu'un à des tests détesté au
quotidien et mettre le blâme sur tous
les problèmes du monde sur les épaules
de notre région va va commencer à
réfléchir sur vigne et où les bombes
site qu'ils ont fait pendant quatre ans
c'était vraiment incroyable tout ce
qu'il y a réussi et j'espère qu'ils vont
commencer à avoir de vraies dubaï dont
le bail donné et rs et la faiblesse de
cette tique et de président vice
président on verra s'il peut vraiment
gérer tous les problèmes du monde comme
champagne bien bien gérer donc je suis
toujours positif que et a toujours une
grosse bévue public un qui croit dans le
principe de dopés par la force de fisker
responsabilité fiscale et tout ça à
independence energy aux états unis et on
reste positive mais les gens les huit
public 1 on va critiquer les autres
républicains tout formateur à voir on
sera là en tout cas pour en parler avec
vous deux sur ce plateau et on vous
inviterai évidemment pour commenter ce
ticket comme vous dites à risque ben et
voir un petit peu leurs résultats dans
les prochaines années merci à vous deux
ports in merci
jean tobo jour d'avoir été avec nous et
ce à la fin de cette émission se
retrouve dans 5 minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité de la journée
[Musique]